[Musique]
le moment c'est un toc toc toc spéciale
europe pourquoi je suis habillée comme
ça qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous des
costumes aux couleurs de l'europe
et moi je suis un petit peu le
présentateur de l'eurovision donc voilà
on a tiré au sort et je suis tombé sur
ce costume bien entendu il ya un mytho
dans ma phrase
attention les chéris c'est parti toc toc
toc spéciale europe on y va qui est là
la suède qui fanent italie à l'eau ou
fantasy halo halo ou où je me sens hyper
tél vous êtes pitoyable pas fou c'est
pas mal pas mal faute et bien sûr pour
le meilleur et pour le meilleur dit ok
les meilleurs toc toc du soir hashtag
toc toc toc binebine et est quelqu'un
qui t'appelle merci deuxième cas
autochtone tous ces partis oliva week
est là la turquie à bas la turquie elle
est très enjoué la turquie unis la
turquie la turquie qui l'église sfc au
parti c'est au parti qui est là mais la
turquie la turquie qui de surcroît qui a
choqué
non tu crois vraiment pas que ce que
disent les grands bon allez mes toiles à
merci
la tristesse du costume pour moi c'est
un peu moi c'est un peu normal et c'est
parti ton petit chien à ses quelqu'un
d'énervé sac et la mic qu'est malte
might malte
malki ça fait mal tu allais seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est très bien attention c'est parti
wick et là c'est la croatie où tu as
croisé qui sait la croatie
[Musique]
longuet
attention le prochain week end
c'est l'école qui ça décosse décosse les
causes qui les causses happiness n'a
atteint 8 et coûteux room n'a rien
compris c'est quoi
directement vous allez directement au
plateau à bout oui vous avez directement
au pape et sean connery
enfin plus tôt le rickshaw et elle est
seulement merci alex aller là bas
merci voilà la buissière même pas
compliqué mais si je joue attaquant du
musée dont vous rappelle merci allez
c'est parti
le coach qui est là c'est là au nom du
ou même a écrit pataude à la hollande
qui hollande de pierre autour des lacs
c'est pour les vivants d'ailleurs brûlé
au vent des landes de pierre du
connemara
[Applaudissements]
merci c'est bien là tout cas le sabot
vous va très très bien et au pineau qui
bon franchement vous êtes très sexy
comme ça cela hollande ça oui ça c'est
pinault qui ont chassé la longue ça beau
hollande mais bah oui aller aux divas
qui est là l'italie et aux pas la peine
de faire cette tête là n'ont pas tous un
peu plus enjouée qui est la litanie
l'état liquide l'état les i à lille mais
tagliani
[Musique]
salut qu'en été
s'il vous plaît arrêtez pourquoi mais
qu'un rapport avait condamné à gc bâton
en double file mais l'italie sur des
collègues a pu mais pas d'avoir bien
ouais c'est avec ces comics au sort leur
est allé si c'est bien là qu'est la la
russie par ici ouais a réussi oui
paramount war halo reach et qui est
content aussi c'est moi je sais il ya
des choses comme ça ça va pas essayer
dépêche-toi deux minutes arrêtez vous
embrasse pascal obispo qui est en train
de céder tout le monde sait ce que je me
disais ça comme ça bravo et sa villa
jeudi d'abord on va la refaire
alesi qui est là jean-michel chili con
mais si les combats vous passant des
années ou quatre ans dernier
laissez-passer la personne avant allait
alors qui est là c'est l'autriche
annonce et agathon koné savoir
autrichiens attendent en commun sont
hélas c'est l'autriche
l'autriche qui l'autriche canaux
officiels aux autres
cette fois c'est la bonne benhaim je
vous d'anciens tu peux toutes les deux
la wii rabaisser mort parce que la lay
line décoincer la concubine en argent
mais c'est vrai allez allez
non mais elle est coincée et mélanie va
être nommé parce qu'il veut bien les
choses vous la chaude et vous affirmez
j'ai la chance ou la chaudière à doloow
bâti musiques actuelles
je fais
non
[Applaudissements]
là je peux moi
à
tout s'explique
descente et révolutionnaire
merci après les raids
elle est raide et apparemment ce n'est
pas la seule merci enfin n'a pas tant
que ça aux excuses moi deux petites
minutes peuvent lire les lignes de la
main sont allés à la grèce tout le monde
sombre mais c'est quoi ces mots là haut
la grèce là qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous voulez enfin en
numéro 1 faisant berné tout le monde et
par attention c'est parti on y va qui
hélas la grèce lagaf' qui graissent que
tu viens pour les vacances
moi je n'ai pas changé
[Applaudissements]
et le chapeau va très bien alors là vous
allez voter sur twitter pour qui a fait
le meilleur un bien sûr toc toc toc